يا اخي الكريم هذه فتره معينه لها ظروفها
والعجله هذه العجله دامت سنوات لا تزال
البنجوغ مستمره منذ 10 سنوات ولكن العزله
مع الكتب بما اني محاط بالكتب فلا اشعر
بالعجله
والفكر هي التي هي رفيقي في هذه العزله
الطويله ولكن عدله انتش فيها ايضا اكتب
اكتب
لانه في كثير ربما علاقتهم بالتقنيه ليست
بشكل
البعض هل هذه تنطبق عليك يعني
ممكن
ممكن تنطبق علي من حيث الشبكات التواصل
الاجتماعي فيسبوك تويتر الى اخره ليس لي
اي علاقه بها اطلاقا يعني انا خارج
شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي كليه
لكن نتراسل فقط عن طريق الايميل الايميل
ايميل موجود ومعروف الكثيرين هذا هو
الفريق الوحيد للتواصل مع الاخرين الايميل
يعني انت ترتاب تخاف من التقنيه تخاف من
الموبايل ماذا
لا لا للموبايل هذا ظرف معين يعني
ظرف معين ولكن سوف سوف اشتري موبايل قريبا
استسلمت يعني الاصدقاء من امثالكم من
امثالكم
اخرج من هذه العزله تدريجيا ان شاء الله
ولا تنسى ان هذا الوباء ايضا ارعى بالناس
اجبارهم ايضا على العزله
في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
ستشارك فيها بفعاليه يعني
التواصل الاجتماعي مع لحد الان لست متحمسه
ابدا
للتواجد في في شبكات الاجتماعيه ما عندي
ايي اي اي حماس الى ما عندي اي حماسيه لا
ممكن يتغير رايي فيما بعد ما اعرفش ولكن
تواصل مع القراء عن طريق مقالات في الشرق
الاوسطن الطريق نعم